welcome everyone this short screencast
is an overview of the lit review we've
reached the project phase of this course
and I think the lit review is a really
crucial element there it's where you
begin to build an intellectual
foundation for your project
fundamentally for me the rationale
behind the lit review is about
productive dialogue we want you to enter
into dialogue with your teammates and
with yourself and with your Mentor from
the teaching team about what you're
going to try to accomplish in the final
project so you should pose questions you
should identify obstacles and propose
initial workarounds you should find data
sets and models and architectures and
everything else and you should think
carefully about your resources the idea
here is to gather Intel from the
literature about what people are doing
in your space and use that information
to begin to carve out an original vision
for your own final projects
the specific requirements are listed at
the course website you can follow the
link at the top of the slide here let me
just offer you a brief rundown first
it's a roughly six page document and we
say eight pages is the max so you don't
go overboard and that does not include
the obligatory references section
we have a template that you can use it's
a latex template based in the ACL format
you're not required to use it but you
might as well and you'll begin to get
used to dealing with that ACL format
which is required for the final paper
groups of one should review five papers
groups of two should review seven and
groups of three should review nine I
think you can hear and there a small
incentive for doing group work which we
think is productive in general
the ideal is to have the same topic for
your lit review and final project
obviously that's the most efficient but
we do grant that sometimes people finish
the their lit review and that leads them
to the realization that they don't want
to work in that area anymore that is
perfectly fine but then you should
negotiate that with your mentor and with
the members of your team to make sure
you can have your actual project
converge in the time available which is
always too short
and then we come to the major things to
include and you might as well use these
phrases as section headings in the
document to help your Mentor understand
what you're trying to do
so General problem task definition this
is absolutely crucial we want to know
what kind of questions you're going to
be asking and you might begin to guide
us toward things that will be crucial
for your project
then we want concise summaries of the
Articles and I will say we're not really
looking for you to just summarize the
content rather the ideal summary is
going to raise questions and identify
issues that will be useful to you in
thinking about the project work itself
and relatedly you should compare and
contrast these articles how do they
differ in terms of models and data and
fundamental results because that too
could help point the way toward space
for an original contribution
and then really importantly let's think
about future work what are you going to
do next how might this all come together
into a project it's never too early to
begin that creative process and the more
you can do Under This heading the more
productive your dialogue with your
Mentor will be and then I think you'll
be able to go farther
and then finally
so that you get in the habit of this and
so that we can identify what literature
items you're reviewing we want an
obligatory references section
in terms of actually conducting lit
review searches I do have some tips that
I have found really productive over the
years so here's the kind of cycle that I
still use regularly
search with some keywords in the ACL
Anthology Google Scholar or semantic
scholar because it's NLP I recommend
starting with the ACL Anthology a
wonderful aspect of the NLP Community is
that it is very well organized when it
comes to its literature
essentially all of the work that's
published by the lcacl is accumulated
into this Anthology which has good
Google search good bib entries abstracts
links to the papers you name it so
that's a good first stop especially if
you're working on a core Topic in NLP
but don't limit yourself to that you
should Branch out also and check Google
Google Scholar and semantic scholar in
this course we really value
interdisciplinary work and so you want
to connect with other literatures
besides NLP in many cases
Next Step download relevant and or
highly cited results and check out their
abstracts and related work sections
these are heuristics relevant will be
delivered by the search engine according
to your keywords and then highly cited
is just a good heuristic for finding
things that have been influential you
shouldn't depend on it but there's no
doubt that it's a useful piece of
information
when you do this you're seeking out key
questions and techniques and also other
highly cited papers you should not read
entire papers at this point that is
tremendously inefficient there are too
many papers out there so you need to use
your time wisely so the idea here is to
get a feel for these papers and also get
a sense for what else they are citing
download the papers that you see
prominently in the related work section
and kind of add those add those to the
set that you downloaded as part of your
course search
and then return to step one with some
new keywords that you gathered as part
of the searching that you did
and you should keep going on that Loop
and break out of it when you have a
sense for what you're doing and what
others have done in the area you'll
start to iterate out around in a few
papers that you think are clearly
important maybe some new directions will
be suggested by the other papers that
are in your set now you've got the basis
for thinking about a selection for the
lit review
at that stage you select some core
papers from that downloaded set and
finally you read those deeply and you
cover those in the lit review notice you
do that only at the final stage so that
you can learn as much as you can by kind
of surveying widely in a lightweight way
and then you go deep once you have a
sense for where to invest
this is sort of amusing a plagiarism
policy it's a specially meta feeling for
us because after all we study large
language models and there's a growing
concern in Academia that these language
models will make it harder for us to
assess student writing let's try to
embrace this a little bit so I did do a
search based on how the electro paper
relates to the Transformers paper this
is with gpd4 and I will confess to you
that what came back looks awfully useful
to me this does look like kind of raw
information that you could use to inform
a lit review so that's all to the good
make sure you know the course policy
though it's linked here and what it
essentially says is there's no rule
against using an AI assistant like gpt4
to help you with your lit review
but all output from the model needs to
be quoted that's per the policy you
treat it like any other resource and of
course assignments that are just
quotations from any resource are not
going to do well in terms of evaluation
assignments with substantial overlap in
Pros will be scrutinized for plagiarism
what that means is that if two groups
used a similar prompt and got back
similar results and included them in the
lit review unquoted they'd probably get
an ad for plagiarism not because they
used a model but because the two
assignments look too much alike and at
that point it's not the language model
that we're implicating here but rather
the standard sort of thing that we see
when we worry about plagiarism
so I would suggest using these
assistants not to produce raw Pros for
you but rather to help you figure out
what's in the literature and you'll want
to be skeptical consumers because well I
think this is a pretty good description
of Elektra and Transformers I haven't
thoroughly audited it and I wouldn't
include it anywhere even paraphrased by
me until I had given it a thorough audit
to make sure that it was all factually
correct because that's the ultimate
thing that we're looking for never mind
where all this prose came from but the
idea here is that there's obviously
value to these things they could
supercharge certain aspects of research
so we don't want to ban them after all
we think they're really interesting
artifacts that's why we're in this
course but we want to use them with
caution and we want to make sure that
they don't end up kind of producing
really bad scholarship that is the
fundamental thing that we're watching
out for
that's it for the lit review it's worth
thinking ahead to the next document
which is a bit more unusual in the
context of this course that's the
experiment protocol this is a short
structured report designed to help you
establish your core experimental
framework and the required sections are
listed here hypotheses data metrics
models General reasoning summary of
progress and references you can see that
that's kind of the raw materials for a
project in this space and we're trying
to look to see whether anything is
missing and when whether there are any
other obstacles that would prevent your
project from converging in the time
available the idea is Clarity around
project goals identification of
obstacles and project risks so you
should be erring on the side of
disclosing too much in the interest of
making sure we overcome all the
obstacles and fill in all the gaps so
that the project succeeds in the end
that's where the protocol but you might
as well be thinking along these lines
for the lit review it is not ever too
early to begin brainstorming about
exactly what the final project is going
to look like even at the lit review
stage you can start to get a feel for
what hypotheses are interesting what
techniques you want to try and so forth
and so on so the earlier the better
that's what all of these preliminary
project assignments are about